♪ ♪
>> LET ME ANSWER YOUR QUESTION,
IF YOU SAY YOU THINK THE WORD OF
STEELWORKER, WHAT WORDS COME TO
YOUR MIND IF YOU SAY
STEELWORKER?
WHAT IS WRONG WITH DEMANDING FOR
AN EASY, SAFE KIND OF FAIR
INCOME.
A PATH TO A SAFE PLACE FOR THEM
TO WIN, OR EXCUSE ME, TO WORK.
>> Laura: YESTERDAY'S
APPEARANCE BY SENATE CANDIDATE
JOHN FEDERMAN HAS A LOT OF
PEOPLE WONDERING IF HE
PHYSICALLY IS UP FOR THIS
CHALLENGE, IT IS SOMETHING HIS
REPUBLICAN CHALLENGER HAS ASKED
ON THE TRAIL AND JOINING ME NOW
IS DR. OZ, REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
DR. OZ, YOUR TEAM HAS COME UNDER
FIRE FOR POINTING OUT LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE STAMINA AND
MENTAL ACUITY AT THIS POINT.
AND ISN'T THAT A FAIR QUESTION
ASKED GIVEN WHAT IS AT STAKE FOR
NOT JUST THE PEOPLE OF
PENNSYLVANIA, BUT FOR THE WHOLE
COUNTRY WITH THIS ONE SENATE
RACE.
>> AS A POSITION I FEEL BAD THAT
HE IS STRUGGLING, BUT THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF WORK YOU HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS FROM THE PRESS AND
FROM VOTERS AND HEAR WHAT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE GOING TO STAY
AND HE HAS JUST NOT BEEN OUT
THERE.
ON THE QUESTION THAT WE ARE
ASKING IS A LEGITIMATE ONE.
ARE YOU HIDING BECAUSE YOU DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT RADICAL
VIEWS?
OR IS IT BECAUSE OF YOUR HEALTH
IS SUCH A PROBLEM, AND IF IT IS
THE STROKE THAT YOU HAVE CAUSING
ISSUES, LET'S FIGURE OUT A WAY
THAT WE CAN HAVE A DEBATE.
IT'S THE BEST WAY FOR US TO
IDENTIFY HOW WE ARE DIFFERENT
FROM EACH OTHER AND LET THE
PUBLIC DECIDE WHO THEY WANT TO
VOTE FOR.
BUT IF IT IS YOUR RADICAL VIEWS
YOU ARE HIDING, I WON'T LET YOU
GET AWAY WITH THAT.
YOU HAVE THE MOST RADICAL
POSITION JOHN FEDERMAN OF ANY
CANDIDATE IN THE CONTENTED RACE
IN THE COUNTRY AND IT'S MY
OBLIGATION AND DUTY THAT VOTERS
IN PENNSYLVANIA APPRECIATE THAT.
>> Laura: IT JUST REMINDS ME
OF THE JOE BIDEN CAMPAIGN IN
2020, HE WAS ESSENTIALLY A
HOLOGRAM CANDIDATE.
THEY ONLY TROTTED AMOUNTS RARELY
AND KIND OF CITED COVID CAMPAIGN
WITH A FEW DEBATES, BUT IT WAS
KID GLOVES TREATMENT TO PROTECT
HIM.
AND YOU SEE SOME OF THE SAME
DYNAMIC AT PLAY HERE AND IT'S ON
EVERY --
ANY IDIOTIC POINT ABOUT
SOMETHING YOU SAID ABOUT
CRUDITES?
THAT IS CLOSE IN PENNSYLVANIA.
AND THEY ARE AGAINST FRACKING
AND CLAIMING THAT THEY ARE FOR
THE FIELDWORKERS AND FOR THE OIL
GUYS.
>> WITHOUT QUESTION, I WILL WALK
YOU THROUGH ONE EXAMPLE, A HOT
TOPIC IN PENNSYLVANIA, ARGUING
WE SHOULD RELEASE ONE-THIRD OF
ALL PRISONERS IN PENNSYLVANIA
AND IS BRIGHT ABOUT ALL THE
MURDERERS THAT HE HAS PARTNERED
YET HE HAS THE HIGHEST LAWYER
RATE EVER AND THAT IS UP 60%
SINCE HE HAS BEEN IN OFFICE.
IN ADDITION, HE WANTS TO
LEGALIZE ALL DRUGS AND THE HERO
AND INJECTION SITES, WE HAVE THE
LARGEST OPEN AIR DRUG SITE IN
PHILADELPHIA IN THE COUNTRY.
AND THEN AN SANCTUARY CITIES AS
AN OPEN BORDER AND DOES NOT
UNDERSTAND THAT INTO THE
COMMUNITIES IN PENNSYLVANIA HAS
BEEN HIT HARSHLY, TOP FIVE IN
THE COUNTRY AND DEATHS, AND THE
ENFORCEMENT RECENTLY WAS
UNANIMOUS, THEY WERE SO ANGRY,
HERE'S THE CATCH, THE COAST,
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK, THEY
ARE HOARDING MONEY.
THEY JUST WANT TO GET THE 51ST
SEAT AND DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
DANGEROUS HE IS, HOW RADICAL HE
IS.
AND THESE ARE GOOD GUYS, COME TO
HELP.
DR. OZ.COM, COME SUPPORT ME AND
MAKE SURE HE CAN ARM UP AND
DEFEND OURSELVES AND ALSO DEFINE
WHO JOHN FEDERMAN'S.
A LOT OF RESOURCES ARE IN THIS
CAMPAIGN.
HE DRAMATICALLY CLOSE THE POLLS
AS YOU KNOW, AND IN ORDER TO
COMPETE YOU HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO
EVERYBODY THAT'S WHO JOHN
FEDERMAN IS.
AS YOU POINT OUT.
>> Laura: DR. OZ, HE IS THE
ULTIMATE PHONY POPULIST.
THEY OBVIOUSLY ARE WORRIED ABOUT
A MORE POPULIST REPUBLICAN PARTY
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALL TRYING TO
PRETEND TO BE POPULOUS.
TIM RYAN IN OHIO DOING THE EXACT
SAME THING, AND JON TESTER IN
MONTANA AND NOW THIS IS JUST THE
MOST RECENT ITERATION.
BUT THEY ARE DESTROYING THE OIL
AND GAS INDUSTRY IS A CLAIM TO
BE FOR THE REGULAR PEOPLE.
IN THE SAME THING WITH THE STEEL
INDUSTRY AS THEY WANT TO SHAPE
OUR JOBS OVERSEAS.
SO THIS PHONY POPULISM WITH THE
HOODIE, THAT HAS TO BE
COMPLETELY EXPLODED AND EXPOSED
FOR WHAT IT IS.
TO ME THAT IS THE WINNING WAY TO
WIN THE ELECTION.
>> IT IS FRUSTRATING BECAUSE HE
CALLS FRACKING A STAIN ON
PENNSYLVANIA AND REGULATION AND
THEN TO HIS OWN HOMETOWN HE SAYS
I WAS EMPHATIC, 2,000 PEOPLE,
IT'S THE PART BY MAYOR, BOMBING
CRISIS QUADRUPLED UNDER HIS
WATCH AND THEN A YEAR AFTER
LEAVING COME OF THE CRIME DROP
60%.
THERE IS A REASON THAT HE HAS
NEVER ACTUALLY HAD A REAL JOB.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF REAL
JOB, HAS HE AGREED TO A REAL
DEBATE, ANY DEBATE?
>> NO, I HAVE ACCEPTED FIVE
MAJOR MEDIA COMPANIES AND
DEBATES AND HE HAS NOT RESPONDED
OR ACCEPTED, I JUST NEED HIM TO
COME OUT AND FIGHT.
HE OWES IT TO THE AMERICANS IN
PENNSYLVANIA TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE HE
STANDS ON THESE ISSUES.
HE IS MORE RADICAL THAN HE
ACKNOWLEDGES.
AND HE IS A HOLOGRAM AS YOU
POINT